[Music]  and this is a breakthrough role for you  jack because  an american accent  yes yes i was doing an american accent  what in that clip yes olivia  he was  it was good thank you very much  you see what a lot of actors do when  they do an american accent  is they tend to just go for like one  region of america and they commit to a  single american accent i decided with  this role that i would take soniter  around all 50 states  sometimes in the same scene i thought  why just do one when you can show off  them all  so i would start the scene talking like  i was from new york and then all of a  sudden i'm suddenly speaking like i'm a  cali girl and by the end of the scene  they're stopping me because it sounds  like i'm from the dukes of hazard i'm  all over the place but i thought you  know just show off your skills  [Music]